did George Santos lie any more than the
average politician yes here's my feeling
yeah let me tell you why I don't know
let me tell you why and this is what I
listened to I took us in a place I
didn't prepare for but but this is what
I think is so interesting about the
Santos thing is usually politicians lie
about what they're going to do for you
and they all lie and everything they
promised they don't deliver on and is
all lies
he lied about who he was and what he
went through
and I think it's really funny that now
what gets you elected is lying about who
you are not lying about what you could
do for people because we're so
desensitized to the lives of the
politicians it don't work no more to
tell me you can do something for me
because I don't think you can do
anything so we're buying into you now
now you got to be [ __ ] trans uh
Holocaust Survivor all these other
[ __ ] things he said and I think is
that what you're saying to like we've
spent so long with people being like hey
I'm gonna help the black community
people are like [ __ ] that we're not
trusting the lives anymore tell me you
black we're just gonna vote for a black
guy because then at least I know you're
not gonna work against it at least be
blind right and that's what he did like
it I don't know I just think it's like
we get caught up in this crazy story and
it's absolutely crazy story what he did
but there is a kernel of Truth in it
that's really fascinating which is
politicians almost ran out of [ __ ] to
lie about
and then he was like there's a whole lot
more like
that's wild right the only difference
and it works only difference that when
politicians lie about what they're gonna
do they can still say like oh I was
trying but the other side is blocking me
yeah yeah but this you can't like take
back any of these lies no I'm blocking
them bro
he was trying they started blocking them
who you are way different than lying
about what you're gonna do yeah that's
weird the only places I promise I'm
gonna take my wife we ain't going
but I am who I say I am but eventually
you could one day you could that hope
yeah that's why it's less bad there's a
hope you could lower taxes like Al said
there's plausible deniability that's a
very important thing and you saying hey
I'm honest I've fought to lower taxes
yeah how can you put me wrong exactly
but saying I am something I'm not it's
like well you're now you are a [ __ ]
liar yeah yeah you're 100 right I'm just
saying there is it is an interesting
time that we would rather just identify
with the politician because we know that
they're not going to do nothing for us
anyway yeah and I think that's the thing
we could take away from this the crazy
part is that like when two politicians
are running against each other they vet
and they look into somebody's past how
did they miss the laziest opponent ever
oh how did they miss he lied about where
he worked he lied about graduating
schools
he was like his grandparents survivors
like that's that's the only thing that
he ain't lied about
really well they survived they wasn't
there but they did survive like yeah
imagine imagine someone's trying to call
him on that [ __ ] and he was like well
did they survive
they didn't they make it yeah how am I
here they were born in 1963 but did they
make it that's funny like yeah if
someone lies about who they are to get
into office and we find out as to lie
should we vote to take them out yes can
you do that yeah I think it depends on
the size of that lie do I think you just
let that be up to the vote and people
yeah as a little live do a revote if if
like part of the reason you got it is
because you said hey I'm this I'm this
I'm this and everyone's like oh I like
you because of this isn't this yeah then
you got it on the false pretense the
people from his district are telling him
to step down they should do that should
there be a legal precedent they're like
hey if you do this and we find out it's
a lie you can you can get revoted out if
if yeah if you lied about kind of who
you are you lied not if you lied about
promises because they all lied but if
you lie about [ __ ] in your control
without costume yeah and things that are
verifiably like okay yeah this is not
should be a Revo yeah 100 but now
they're going to get them on uh campaign
finances because like all of a sudden
running all that money he went from
making like 55 000 for like the past
five years to all of a sudden one year
he made like seven hundred thousand
that's all you love her wow you started
elimination and then that'd be like
crazy he donated his campaign some crazy
amount of money so it's just like all
right somebody came with the big bag be
like ah we tapping you to be it's a run
yeah you got to do what you got to do to
make it and then but it's crazy but
ain't that on us a little bit too like
is it on us the voters that that we're
doing this like we're just looking for
representation instead of like the best
person for the job yeah like and none of
us vote locally I'm not gonna vote local
I vote locally
I just think that is a kind of
interesting thing is like like if we
just went out for the best person for
the job regardless if it was like I
think this goes to what we were speaking
about earlier hopefully it's in the
episode when we're talking about um
uh maybe it was a
uh the car insurance or that kind of
stuff but exactly like if if you're not
judging a book by its cover you're just
judging a book by how well they [ __ ]
drive the car and that's how much you
got to pay right and it's like
if if we are are looking for the best
person for the job whether they're a
[ __ ] Jewish guy who's 64 years old
whether they're a Chilean chick who's 23
like if they're just the best person in
the job we just remove the identity
politics then maybe we'll end up with
that yeah but we're so caught up in the
identity politics that we're rooting for
these people we're voting for these
people that might not even be the best
for the job and if they are their
qualifications can't just be that they
check off boxes you know like yeah
it's just how do you know who's best for
the job because yeah we all lie yeah I
mean you can at least read what they're
going to try to do
that's what I was saying like is this
the Readjustment like you know the
Readjustment we were talking about the
guy who won the custody is like is that
the read is the uh the over correction
yeah like will this be the over
correction we'll be like all right well
maybe we should stop just voting people
in for identity and then this one's like
all right maybe we should stop just
letting people stay there whatever so
they can win their kids back maybe we
need another kind of well you get a
politician do what you want to do is you
gotta pay him a lot of money yeah so I'm
wondering how much money like how much
money do you have to pay to get them to
do even like a little bit do you know
like how much are these super Pacs
paying like millions of dollars but he
was doing this before them like the dude
was
like to do like lived with another dude
and was like selling them these dreams
about all this other [ __ ] he's just like
a manipulative power hungry [ __ ]
but all these politicians are like
they're all willing to sort of Bend
things for money yeah so I'm like could
you could you pay a politician
a couple hundred thousand just to get
them to do a small thing like just like
include you in a speech oh yeah yes how
much could that cost
I mean Obama did that question Lil Wayne
paid Obama to hey to mention him in the
speech you didn't remember that yes Lil
Wayne paid him 400 000 to mention him
worth it that's just hella worth it if
you say on the record that's what
happened as we say it the last podcast
on the left tell me online
area
what was that podcast it was like he
says
no there was a podcast
with a comic what's his name Ben
something yeah yeah they cover serial
killer [ __ ] oh my bad I'm thinking about
a liberal podcast what is it like a
bunch of guys one of the guys used to
write the speeches for Obama oh
um this is America cereal no this is
America yeah no not this is America this
American life This American Life that's
that's the one are you sure it's that
one I don't think it's fresh the fresh
air podcast
thank you
that's how Grandpa we are I don't even
know that podcast thought that she was
last podcast on the left
doesn't that sound like a liberal no
doesn't that sound like a like no it
does but it's such a problem no more
podcasts for liberals this is the last
one on the left that's the last one yeah
it's a popular podcast probably by
liberal Cox it's probably liberal
constant listen to it it's a serial
killer pumpkin all her girlfriends are
probably listening to it the liberal
clocks down
like you could pay her and you can make
her slip in a funny word say titties in
your next Peach just saying yeah she
would and you'll just we'll give you a
hundred thousand what about AOC you
could get her I genuinely think if you
pay enough money you could get her to
fit you in how much do you think it
would cost for her to talk about the
four Locos
yeah AOC because she don't take
donations right everyone takes donations
just gotta be big enough she's taking
donations of ginger
Harry's [ __ ] AOC sorry
I'm good the guy that wrote 18 was
[ __ ] for real that's crazy talk about
head like that yeah
anyway we gotta find a politician to go
donate a bunch of money to and change uh
American politics all right his
stupidest waste of money let's do it